while i don't want to give too much away
about what strange things await players
below the shop overcoming these
challenges will reward you with a shop
of your own
what where you can sell items and gear
at better rates than anywhere else
in the shopkeeper's cosmetic set a right
proper outfit for the entrepreneurial
hogwarts student
excuse me what we can get our own shops
in this game are you kidding me so here
we go a dark secret awaits and hogwarts
legacy's haunted hogsmeade playstation
exclusive quest which we have now
learned is for one year of exclusivity
so good news bad news there for the xbox
pc and switch folks you will get to play
it just gonna be waiting a year so
hopefully the game is long let's say you
won't have to worry about it but hey i
mean it's like fresh new content a year
in you'll be able to look forward to
that will you brave the darkness that
lies beneath the haunted hogs meat shop
here's the main new stuff here the
haunted hogs meat shop and we're not
done yet today we also have a peek at
the playstation exclusive quest the
haunted hogs meat shop this mysterious
quest is built into the core game and
can be discovered by any witch or wizard
playing on playstation okay good so it's
not just deluxe if you're playing on any
version of playstation you get it so
again exclusive quest additional dungeon
shopkeepers cosmetic and in-game hogs
meet shop
dude we get our own shop
cassandra mason that was the one of the
leaked names from way way way back way
back in our hogwarts legacy uh news
cycle cassandra mason has a shop to sell
you in hogsmeade but all is not as it
seems in this rundown establishment what
sinister secrets lie beneath madame
mason's shop and why was she so keen to
sell it that's a mystery hogwarts legacy
players will discover in the haunted
hogsmead meet shopquest exclusively
available on playstation platforms again
for one year while i don't want to give
too much away about what strange things
await players below the shop overcoming
these challenges will reward you with a
shop of your own
what where you can sell items and gear
at better rates than anywhere else
and the shopkeeper's cosmetic set a
right proper outfit for the
entrepreneurial hogwarts student
excuse me what we can get our own shops
in this game are you kidding me because
this to me hints at surely they wouldn't
have a whole shop that you can like
become an entrepreneur running
that wouldn't be the only way to get it
well this one
yeah but dude
they are going all in with the cosmetics
for this game man
all in additionally if you pre-order any
ps4 or ps5 version of hogwarts legacy
you'll gain access to the felix felicis
potion recipe felix felicis dressing
that three times fast is a luck potion
that reveals gear chest on the minimap
for one in-game day
interesting okay
starting to get a little bit more
details on how the time of the game
might work day night cycles all that
sort of thing so it is a luck potion
that reveals geared chests on the
mini-map
for one in-game day
giving you a pretty lucky day on your
journey as you explore hogwarts and the
surrounding areas so that's in game day
that's not like a full real world 24
hours this is just the recipe though
you'll still need to make the most of
your potions lessons and the room of
requirement potion stations to brew this
bottle of liquid luck by choosing one of
our upgraded editions of hogwarts legacy
players will gain access to additional
in-game cosmetics including the only way
to get a flying thestral mount in the
game the digital deluxe edition also has
72 hour early access and a digital
crosston upgrade allow you to upgrade
from the ps4 version to the ps5 all
pre-orders for hogwarts legacy will get
the onyx hip grip mount so reiterating a
little bit about the pre-order stuff
because it did get kind of crazy
hogwarts legacy deluxe and digital
deluxe edition okay
so they've added
the felix felices here for the
playstation version
also showing the thestral again which we
we've already seen that dark arts
cosmetics 72 hours dark arts battle
arena and then this little area here so
this is the hard copy deluxe and then
the
digital deluxe
gets also gets the dark arts garrison
hat don't ask me why it's only for the
digital i have no idea but that's how
they're doing it
okay
and then we have the collector's edition
let's see here
looks like nothing new has been added to
this one
which like they're still advertising
this so do they have more to sell
nobody's been able to get one except
from gamestop and just a few people got
in on best buy and a few on amazon
hogwarts legacy launches on february 10
2023 on ps4 and ps5 ladies and gentlemen
that was a lot of news that was a lot of
news but as always thank you all so much
for watching
i'll talk to you again soon